this is part two of the story of me
discovering my biological father if you
want to see part one click here I kind
of pointed out hi my name is vine
mailing I'm an orthopedic surgeon in the
New York metropolitan area I do a lot of
trauma surgery sports medicines things
like that I also started a stem-cell
company with my friend Eddie so when I
was at Ohio State I used to wait tables
and things like that so I decided to go
ahead and look into being a sperm donor
so they would pay you you know every
time you went over and donated and then
I went on to medical school and I moved
to Dayton and I just kind of lost track
of it never told anyone when I was
donating you know so didn't really think
about it all that much a couple years
ago I saw the movie about where he
donates sperm and he ends up with all
these kids you are the biological father
of 533 children what that made me kind
of think I'd be interesting to know if I
ever fathered any kids and then also I
have this stem-cell business and I was
interested to see if maybe there might
be some of the sperm left in their
freezer because I could give me some
information about whether my genetic
makeup has changed from doing all these
stem cell treatments and then all of a
sudden I found out for my sister that
one of the kids apparently who I had
fathered through the sperm bank
they both matched up through ancestry
DNA her parents
use sperm from the sperm bank you know
my sperm basically to have their two
kids so I was just checking my phone and
between my surgeries and my sister had
texted me and she wanted to tell me
something really important I said yeah
go ahead and release my information I
open up the email and I read it and it
has his name his email his phone number
and that he's open to talking I'm kind
of just freaking out a bit and the first
thing I can think is just to call my
brother at the time he didn't want to
know anything he just want to know
health details and that was it
then I craft this email yeah at the time
I wasn't thinking about what to call it
I was more so even just thinking what
till I put in the subject line how is
this conversation gonna go like hi Bryan
thanks for your sperm like I was just
like hey I gave a little bit of
background on me and and then I gave him
my contact information so what my
friends were like no don't meet them
they're gonna want you to bail them out
from whatever financial crisis that
they're in I said you know I really need
to know you know I how could I just not
know who these people were so then he
reads the email and he responds very
quickly it was actually on the treadmill
at the gym this was also the day before
my 22nd birthday
I'm opening like four text messages in a
row I had an email he sounds super
excited wants to get in contact which is
great I sent him a picture of me and my
brother and he sent some pictures of him
he said that I could Google him but I
already had yeah so then we set up a
call for later in the day it was kind of
just like hey what's up I could put a
face and a voice to the missing entity
but yeah we had a good conversation he
told me about why he donated sperm in
college it was to pay for medical school
so that makes sense to be perfectly
honest at the time I just did it because
I you know needed you know money looks
like it was a good investment because
he's very successful now he thought the
whole thing was cool
he told his whole family and they're all
excited none of them knew that he had
donated sperm and then he said he wanted
to meet me and my brother and my parents
I was gonna be in Connecticut for a work
event the following week if you're in
New York I can easily just take the
train and we can meet I said well hey
why don't we all get together for dinner
and so we all met up at Capitol Club at
the time my brother still not wanted to
be involved in anything he was still mad
at me that I told him that he met Brian
the donor lived in New York City anyway
he eventually decides to come to dinner
I walked right in I saw him and then I
turned right around and I regrouped and
then turned around to get in they go in
said hi I don't know he walk into a
restaurant and you're like that's your
genetic 1/2 in front of you I don't know
it's surreal
I think once we all started kind of
talking and getting to know each other
everyone kind of felt a lot more relaxed
kind of just got to know him he got to
know us they kind of thought maybe I
might be married with a bunch of kids or
something they didn't really of course
no we talked a lot about his career he
has this whole side business um with
stem cells he talked a little bit about
his family I could see some resemblance
so well Samantha really looks like one
of my sisters we seem to have a lot of
the same kind of interests and things
like that our finger 5th finger goes off
to the side a little bit so I guess mine
does a little bit as well and
just had a really fun dinner and then
we're like oh we'll have to you know
meet up again soon and that type of
thing so we kind of leave dinner
thinking now what you know we didn't
really know where this was gonna go it
all happened very very quickly
most people don't find that out in a day
and then talk to the person that same
day and then meet them in the next week
for a while you know you look in the
mirror differently not knowing what the
other genetic half of you is you start
to even told one thing your whole life
and now you look in the mirror and
you're like well yep where does my mouth
come from or you know fit certain
physical features that you didn't
question before that now you're like
well I don't know what the other genetic
half is now when I look in the mirror I
can you know complete the picture of
what makes me me I think that every kid
has a right to know where they come from
so I guess the message is you might as
well be honest from the get-go because
sooner or later technology's gonna catch
up with you at the time we had not told
our parents that we found out who it was
that we talked with him and that we met
him or anything we were kind of gonna
sort it out ourselves first see where it
goes and then tell our parents once we
were ready so my mom knew that I had
been searching for the donor she
actually did text me any luck with your
donor search and I said no at the time
even though I had yes there was luck and
I met him you know they waited 21 and a
half years so I figured you know a month
would be fine the whole thing was funny
because turns out Brian had gotten my
brother and fiancee take it to the US
Open so kind of like a last minute type
thing they were just getting back from
London ninth couple extra tickets yes
who else is gonna be at least okay
my mom
[Music]